hey there everybody my name is Kate
Hendrix I am the senior technical and
gameplay designer on Ark survival
evolved and on the scorched earth
expansion pack and we are here today to
show you all the cool new stuff that is
available in scorch dirt we've got a
whole bunch of new weapons a whole bunch
of new items bunch of new creatures to
tame and to fight with and - you can
even take these little dudes over here
these jerboas and shove them on your
shoulder have them ride around with you
we've got vultures that you can use for
collecting meat and other things from
corpses we've got giant rock golems that
you can see up on the cliff face there
that are amazing siege engines and just
tanky monsters we've got all sorts of
new flying ones that you can through a
very difficult process tame and make
your own we've got a lot a lot a lot of
stuff to show off here so we should
probably just get started with it and
head off in this direction to the little
house that we have built over here for
you you can see on the outside here we
have these really really pretty flags
these flags are the new boss flag that
you get for defeating the manticore boss
he is the new boss that comes with
scorched earth if you manage to defeat
all of the caves get the artifacts from
inside and conquer the boss we've got
his head mounted on the wall right here
this is also a trophy that you can get
from defeating him we actually created
kind of a bunch of different kinds of
trophies that are available to players
who defeat the manticore not just these
like cosmetic items but also a number of
skins that you can get for helmets and
shields there are a number of new
creatures that I mentioned we've got
these little jug bugs here these are
some of the cool new kind of helpful
creatures that exist in the deserts
these ones in particular are the
water-jug bugs you can just go up to
them and you can click on the e button
and it allows you to drink the water
inside
them so if you're out in the desert and
you see one and he's flying around you
don't even have to own him you just go
up press the button and you can fill
your water bottom it is one of many ways
that we have kind of put together in
order to help players to survive better
in the desert environment
the red ones oil jug bugs they happen to
contain oil in their big butts it is a
very very efficient source of oil allows
you to kind of collect it without having
to setup yourself on one of the large
oil nodes that can be a little bit
difficult to find and even more
difficult to try and defend a little guy
gonna get out of our way here let's move
you this here's the whip the whip is
actually really nice because you can use
it to hurt these guys all dinosaurs
respond to the whip doesn't hurt them it
just allows you to move them in a
direction and kind of hurt your
creatures it's one of the cool things
that the whip does so we're going to
take you over this way actually because
I believe all of the creatures that I
want to show off are in this direction
here we have the Lamont Rhea it is a
large mouth light creature they are
fliers and they have this really cool
special ability that allows them to drop
this huge bomb of kind of poison gas
when you you have them attack this
poison gas causes a massive slow and
debilitates anything that's caught in
the area of effect it is super effective
during sieges during other kinds of
fights like that
to debilitate and weaken down your
enemies if you want to follow me over
here you are welcome to stay on okay you
know that's cool too we have some other
creatures these are the mantises so the
Mantis is kind of a really interesting
creature they are very very fragile very
low health but they have these you can
see that they have weapons
on them yeah you can equip pretty much
any weapon that a normal player could be
put on these guys and using them
attacking with them all that kind of
stuff it works exactly like you would
expect it would work with a player if
you cut down trees with the guys who
have axis the axes give you the normal
bonuses to harvesting wood that kind of
stuff you can equip swords you can equip
pipes you can equip all sorts of things
in these guys as hands and they actually
get the stats of the weapons that you
equip it makes these guys very very very
deadly they're incredibly powerful but
they are also very very fragile so if
you're going into battle with one of
them that leap there is exactly how you
can get in or out of combat without
dying the leap is very very devastating
it lunges you in but if you go into
combat and you're not prepared you can
end up cut down very quickly by your
opponent's the thorny dragons over here
these guys are one of my favorite they
function just like the beaver does the
beaver if you're not familiar in the
main game has kind of a like Forge built
into its saddle so you can access their
inventory and treat them exactly like
you would a normal smithy they have
reduced weight when they are carrying
wood stone and other basic crafting
materials but these guys have a very
very special attack when you right-click
they shoot out a hail of spines that
induce a large amount of torpor on your
enemies good for knocking people
unconscious knocking enemies unconscious
taming new creatures they are incredibly
versatile and make for a fantastic kind
of like mid-range mount so over here we
have the Marella tops the Marella tops
are kind of our camels of the desert
they are a relatively slow and
methodical creature they're durable but
the most interesting thing about them
honestly is that you can store water in
them and you can safely store water in
them most
water storage options that you have in
the desert here leak they slowly lose
water over time or they are completely
static you can't bring them anywhere
the mirela tops allows you to kind of
breaks that rule by storing water in its
back and they will never leak water you
can go up to them and you can simply
choose an option from the from the use
menu to fill water containers you can
drink water directly from them you can
do a whole bunch of different things
with the water that you store inside of
them and that makes them pretty much
essential for any travel across the
desert because of how difficult it is to
do so and retain your water levels so
here we have the rock elementals these
guys are as I mentioned before these
huge tanky monstrous creatures they are
incredibly slow incredibly methodical
but they have a lot of siege potential
like they can deal damage to a lot of
different types of structures and their
right-click allows them to grab and hurl
these giant boulders the deal tons of
damage they smash up walls they're
really really really cool they also have
a really really neat ability if you just
aim at them and hold down the e button
there's an option to disguise as rock
you can click that disguise this rock
button and after a few seconds the Golem
will disguise itself as a rock it's just
like a normal rock nobody can tell the
difference until they get close to it or
if they happen to own it
and then while they're in rock form you
can go up to them whenever you'd like
and just press e and they will emerge
from rock mode ready for battle so you
can use these for planning ambushes for
catching people unwary
and you can also have these guys kind of
spring up on you in the wild because
that is how you will find them is
disguised as rocks and they will pop out
and immediately attack you they are very
very scary and can only be knocked out
by siege class weaponry which is
explosives or explicit siege weapons
like canyons or catapult stones those
kinds of things farther along the ridge
we have kind of the keystone of scorched
earth these guys here are the wyverns
they come in three different flavors
fire electricity and acid they all have
their own unique breath weapons that
they use just as you would kind of
expect from a dragon or wyvern in this
case they are incredibly powerful
creatures very very difficult to tame
they all have their own unique kind of
skins they've got their own unique
powers you can use the right-click to
fire their breath weapon if you want to
see how that works
the Lightning woman's obviously shoot a
huge bolt of lightning the poison
woman's shoot a massive ball of acid
that explodes into a huge cloud of just
dead and B fire ribbon so as you would
expect breathe fire all over everything
all of these different attacks that they
have kind of have different properties
the poison deals damage over time it
deals its own like type of damage it's a
poison damage that it deals so it can't
be reduced by armor or by normal things
that would reduce the damage that you
take from different sources it's the
same for all of the wyverns the electric
and fire both steel electric and fire
type damage it's kind of an introduction
to elemental type damages and none of
them are reduced by armor or anything
like that so it makes them exceptionally
strong so one of the great thing about
having flyers is that you can see kind
of everything that's going on around you
we've got a t-rex down here who is
currently fighting with one of the pair
sareth areum's
the desert dunes are the scariest place
on scorched earth it is completely
inhospitable out here everything wants
to kill you everything is lethal the
play you don't want to get caught out
here unless you have tons of water
tons of powerful creatures to back you
up like it's it's really bad news if you
get caught out here alone there are a
number of Oasis's and little kind of
safe spots out in the desert but not
enough that you want to be roaming it
without knowing what you're doing and
where you're going oh thank you very
much for sitting down and talking with
me about scorched earth it is available
now on PC on the steam store it's 20
bucks there's a ton of new content here
all sorts of new creatures new caves a
bunch of beautiful environments to
explore
you know what we put a huge amount of
passion a huge amount of just like love
being to this it's super polished you
will absolutely love it if you just sit
down and play it it's also available on
Xbox currently on the Microsoft Store
just pop on over pick up again think
thank you so much for sitting down and
running through all this content with me
it was a ton of fun and I look forward
to seeing kind of how scorched-earth and
the rest of the game develop